this is everything we did at disney
california adventures lunar new year
festival so of course the first thing we
all wanted to do was check out all the
delicious food at the lunar new year
marketplace not gonna lie the food
prices can stack up but luckily we were
able to get sip and savor passes which
are 43
and three dollars off if you're a magic
key holder
honestly it's pretty worth it if you
choose items that are eight dollars or
more
which is most of the menu to be honest
my favorites were the mickey purple
sweet potato macaron because it
literally tastes like ube the garlic
noodles because i'm filipino i love
garlic the bon me and the tiger milk tea
which actually had really good boba i
was impressed pro tip that i didn't know
until after but you can order everything
that you want from one booth and then
pick up the food at another booth
there's about eight booths in total that
offer different kinds of food so this
will definitely save you a lot of time
here's some of our favorite booths red
dragon spice traders offers spicy three
cup chicken impossible lions head
meatballs mickey purple sweet potato
macaron and dancing firecracker
longevity noodle co offers garlic
noodles spicy pork danda noodles and the
salted pistachio cold brew prosperity
bow buns offers char shoe barbecue pork
bao and the mickey chinese hot dog bun
and the daddy of them all paradise
garden grill which offers the pork
bonney sandwich spicy kung pao tofu
tiger milk tea and the green tea
raspberry parfait there's obviously a
lot more but these are the ones that had
some of our favorite dishes
after we ate to our hearts content we
wanted to meet our asian disney
princesses mulan and raya mulan taught
us how to bao and raya taught us a cool
warrior pose she even answered some
questions for us do you know what your
lunar new year zodiac animal is i have
to ask my boss
we also wanted to ask what your favorite
food is my favorite food has to be
so yeah we got to meet ryan mullan that
was really cool you can also meet the
classic disney characters like mickey
minnie and the three pigs decked out in
festive gear a trip to disneyland isn't
complete without watching the parade
which features the one and only mulan
and since it's year of the tiger of
course they brought tigger to the parade
so cute the whole procession itself
really felt like mulan the movie was
brought to real life it was so beautiful
to watch the parades happen throughout
the day so definitely don't miss out on
it there's a lot of other activities you
can do like write down your new year
wish i wished for peace compassion and a
little extra green in my life
if you have a little extra money to
spend even after probably spending her
life savings getting a disney ticket
check out the exclusive lunar new year
merch there's a lot of options but i
think the spirit jersey is especially
gorgeous which i ended up getting for
myself i also want to take a second to
appreciate the decor disney really went
all out with it it was so gorgeous to
look at especially during night time
when they lit up
as a filipino american my family didn't
grow up celebrating lunar new year but
i've always enjoyed seeing the
festivities in places like disneyland
and seeing my east and southeast asian
friends celebrating with their families
and getting the extra monies with the
red envelopes it's made me really
appreciative of the diverse cultures
within our asian community and i'm very
happy to learn and celebrate alongside
them
[Music]
you